vraiment de tous les sens,
ce qui permet de transformer des tasses,
de les imprégner de la magie de l'Internet,
jusqu'à possiblement changer ce nuage numérique
en quelque chose que l'on peut toucher et déplacer.
Les parents, choqués par la prédominance des écrans,
auront besoin de jouets numériques pour apprendre à leurs enfants à lire,
en plus d'applications familiales sûres.
Et je pense que c'est déjà le cas.
La réalité est plus riche que les écrans.
Par exemple, j'adore les livres.
Ils me font voyager dans le temps ; les atomes et les molécules se lient,
du moment de leur création au moment de mon expérience.
Mais franchement,
le contenu est le même sur mon téléphone.
Alors, qu'est-ce qui fait du livre une expérience plus riche que l'écran ?
Je veux dire, scientifiquement.
Bien sûr, nous avons besoin d'écrans.
Je vais vous montrer un film, J'ai besoin de cet énorme écran.
Ces boîtes magiques vous permettent cependant d'aller beaucoup plus loin.
Votre téléphone n'est pas l'apanage de l'Internet.
(Rires)
Nous pouvons construire des choses, des choses physiques,
en utilisant la physique et les pixels,
afin d'intégrer l'Internet au monde qui nous entoure.
Je vais vous en donner quelques exemples.
Il y a un certain temps, j'ai travaillé pour une agence de design, Berg,
sur un projet de recherche à propos de l'Internet sans écran.
J'ai alors découvert de nombreux moyens
qu'a la lumière de travailler avec nos simples sens et avec des objets tangibles
pour vraiment rendre l'Internet plus vivant, pour le rendre plus tangible.
Ce YouTube player mécanique en est un merveilleux exemple.
Et cela a été une source d'inspiration pour moi.
J'ai ensuite travaillé pour l'agence japonaise, AQ,
sur un projet de recherche sur la santé mentale.
Nous voulions créer un objet
pouvant analyser les données subjectives relatives aux sautes d'humeur,
si essentielles au diagnostic.
Cet objet est sensible au toucher,
de sorte que vous pouvez le presser fermement lorsque vous êtes fâché,
ou le caresser si vous êtes calme.
C'est comme un emoji stick numérique.
Vous pourriez alors revoir ces instants plus tard,
et leur ajouter du contexte en ligne.
Par-dessus tout,
nous voulions créer un bel objet intime
qui pourrait entrer dans votre poche
et que vous aimeriez.
Ces jumelles ont été offertes comme cadeau de fête
pour le 40e anniversaire de l'Opéra de Sydney.
Nos amis de Tellart à Boston nous ont apporté une paire de jumelles de rue,
le genre que vous pourriez trouver au sommet de l'Empire State Building,
et ils les ont équipées de vues à 360 degrés
d'autres sites du patrimoine mondial --
(Rires)
en utilisant Street View.
Nous les avons ensuite coincées sous les marches.
Elles sont donc devenues cette simple réappropriation physique,
ou comme un portail vers ces autres emblèmes.
Vous pourriez donc voir Versailles ou la case de Shackleton.
C'était en fait la réalité virtuelle vers 1955.
(Rires)
Au bureau, nous utilisons des balles hacky pour échanger des URL.
C'est incroyablement simple, c'est comme utiliser votre Navigo.
Pour faire simple, vous mettez un site web sur cette petite puce,
et puis vous faites ceci et ... voilà! -
le site Web apparaît sur votre téléphone.
Cela coûte environ 10 cents.
Treehugger est l'un de nos projets en collaboration
avec Grumpy Sailor et Finch, ici à Sydney.
Et je suis très excité à propos de ce qui pourrait arriver
si vous démontiez vos téléphones et si vous mettiez les morceaux dans des arbres,
et parce que mes enfants pourraient avoir l'occasion
de visiter une forêt enchantée guidés par une baguette magique,
où ils pourraient parler à des fées numériques et leur poser des questions,
et se faire questionner en retour.
Comme vous pouvez le voir,
nous n'en sommes qu'à l'étape initiale avec celle-ci.
(Rires)
Mais je suis très excité
à l'idée que les enfants retournent jouer dehors sans écran,
mais avec toute la puissante magie de l'Internet au bout des doigts.
Et nous espérons faire fonctionner quelque chose comme ceci d'ici la fin de l'année.
Maintenant, récapitulons.
Les êtres humains aiment les solutions naturelles.
Les êtres humains adorent l'information.
Les êtres humains ont besoin d'outils simples.
Ces principes devraient guider notre façon de planifier l'avenir,
et pas seulement pour l'Internet.
Vous n'êtes peut-être pas à l'aise avec notre entrée dans l'âge de l'information.
Vous la voyez comme un défi à relever même si elle vous excite.
Devinez quoi ? Moi aussi !
C'est vraiment une époque extraordinaire de l'histoire humaine.
Nous construisons notre propre monde
il n'y a aucune forme d'intelligence artificielle ...
encore.
(Rires)
C'est nous -- stylistes, architectes, artistes, ingénieurs.
Et si nous prenons le temps d'y réfléchir,
je pense que nous pouvons effectivement avoir notre endroit préféré
rempli des informations que nous aimons
que nous trouvons aussi simple et naturel qu'une ampoule.
Et bien que ça puisse sembler inévitable
que le public veuille des montres, des sites web et des widgets,
peut-être veut-il plutôt du liège, de la lumière et des balles hacky.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)